[Music]
thank you
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know
for those of you who are tuning in for
the first time this is a question and
answer program sponsored by some TV
where you send us your questions and we
do the research in and in so far there
is an answer we will try and find an
answer and do it here on the air I want
to give you the email address where you
can send us your questions it'll be on
the screen TV at some tv.org once again
TV at some tv.org I also want to remind
you that this is a self-supporting
Ministry we appreciate the donations
that are sent to keep us on the air and
we also appreciate your prayers that the
Lord will bless us and keep us on track
in presenting present truth amen I have
with me my dear friend Pastor Salazar
thank you uh it's always a pleasure to
have him with me thank you uh here on
the program also Daniel Miranda
sometimes uh thank you for being here
and for spearheading this uh program in
Spanish
thank you Pastor board it's a blessing
for me to be able to share with you this
program one of my favorite programs as
well and uh I really enjoyed the fact
that we can communicate and talk with
our friends who are you know sending us
their questions their inquiries is a
blessing to be able to study and be
challenged as well amen praise the lord
well we want to get right into our
program but before we start answering
the first question we do want to ask the
Lord to be present through the ministry
of his holy spirit amen so I want to ask
Pastor Salazar to please pray for us
absolutely let us pray Heavenly Father
we are so thankful Lord that we can come
to you to your throne of grace and to
ask you Lord to give us the biggest gift
that you can provide for us which is the
holy spirit we know that in ourselves we
don't have any knowledge or any uh truth
in ourselves but only that which is
inspired through your word so we humbly
ask that he will use us so that your
words may speak through us and may be a
blessing to those that are listed and
watching I pray all these in Jesus name
amen amen
all right we have a question we don't
know where the person lives we do have a
name but we don't want to share the name
uh it was sent to us in May and I might
mention something you say it was sent in
May and you're answering it in July
yes the reason why is because we receive
more questions than we're able to answer
in one program so we put them all in
order and we answer them in the order in
which we receive them but please be
patient keep tuning in and eventually we
will get to your question uh the
important thing is just to keep in tune
amen with the program each week so
here's the question what will happen to
the rest of church members when the
ceiling is done
will they die as the people died when
the high priest came out of the most
holy place on the day of atonement or as
did the firstborn sons did in Egypt so
the question is uh you know what's going
to happen to the members who were shown
not to be faithful in the investigative
judgment well I can think of several
examples in the Bible of something
similar to these close enough probation
or close enough the Judgment when that
is taken care of or is done you know in
the in the in the heaven century and I
will go to the story of Noah the book of
you know the story of no one Genesis
we remember that when the message or the
time for not to come into the ark
he went into the ark
there after he entered into the ark and
all the animals were in the ark they
closed the door closed the angel closed
the door
yet nothing happened immediately
apparently you know everything seemed to
go as normal as that every day the rain
did not come right away there was no
flood right away and the people that
were outside who had heard and had the
chance many of them were had professed
to be Believers and they were not only
hidden they were actually people who
firmly professed to be you know
followers of God but they rejected the
warning they rejected the message they
did not follow you know in entering to
the ark so to them
it seems that nothing happened but in
effect that provision had closed and
their decision their their fate was
sealed and you know crisis speaks there
in verse 39 or 24 of Matthew speaking of
these people says a new not they knew
nothing they thought everything was fine
until the flood came and took them all
away social also the coming of the son
of manvi so I believe that when the
closer provision ends when the time of
you know the day of atonement is
finished the church members who have not
professed and those are professed to
nothing's gonna happen automatically you
know but we will be unable to no longer
change our decision our faith have been
sealed for eternity yeah you know uh
uh question has to do with the day of
atonement right um Bible says that those
who do not sympathize with the work of
the high priest on the day of atonement
uh were cut off from among the people in
other words they were not members of the
people of God anymore right and other
texts say that they would be destroyed
it doesn't mean that immediately when
the high priest came out that they were
destroyed or cut off from among other
people right but the time came when that
happened in other words there's a
difference between the ceiling and when
the destruction comes uh and of course
the the clearest biblical passage on the
ceiling is Ezekiel chapter nine uh where
you have uh you know the man with an
incorn in his hand and he's dressed in
linen and he has a seal in his hand and
he's commanded to seal those who sigh
and cry because of the Abominations that
were being committed in the city it's
interesting that this is not a judgment
of the pagans exactly this is a judgment
of the people the professed people of
God who were in Jerusalem right in the
same way at the end of time the Judgment
before the second coming is of those who
profess Christ some of them are sign and
crying because of the Abominations that
are being done in the church and others
are participating in those Abominations
and so after the ceiling we're told that
the destruction comes
but the destruction doesn't come
immediately because when you go to
chapter 11 of Ezekiel it says that the
glory of God in the sanctuary after the
ceiling is over departed from the temple
that's when the Holy Spirit leaves the
Earth absolutely and it went and it
stood on the Mount of Olives for a while
and then after it lingered for a while
in the Mount of Olives then
Nebuchadnezzar came and he destroyed the
city
so the destruction did not come
immediately the decision of who was
going to be saved when Nebuchadnezzar
came to destroy the city and those who
were going to be destroyed when
Nebuchadnezzar came that decision had
already been made in the sanctuary but
the destruction takes place sometimes
later
and you know that the same thing
happened with the destruction of the
second destruction of Jerusalem
absolutely you know you have first of
all all of the faithful Christians leave
those in the city are not destroyed
immediately no but then the Romans come
and they destroy all of those who did
not flee with the faithful of God and so
and in the in the story that you brought
up uh in Genesis you know the door
closes right a period of time passes
when the faith of those inside the arka
is tested yes and when those outside
become more and more confident that
nothing's going to happen and then of
course comes the destruction so the
point is there's going to be a period of
time between the when everybody is
sealed
and with the destruction of those who
are not sealed will take place
absolutely absolutely
praise the Lord all right so let's go to
the next question the only three Pastor
board the next question all right please
the next question is very interesting uh
it says I've always thought that sin
in any manner of form is a transgression
of God's law and will therefore lead to
death
however I am a bit confused when I read
first John 5 16 and 17 which seems to
imply that certain sins may not
necessarily lead to death
I am not sure that I do not fully
understand the context of the verse
could you please explain the meaning of
the foregoing verse thank you
so that's a interesting question in
regards to that
passage there in first John 5 16-17
and I'll read it faster and then you
help me answer this question it says
there
If any man see his brother saying a sin
which is not unto death he shall ask
and he shall give him life for them that
sin is not unto death there is a sin
unto death I do not say that he shall
pray for it
all unrighteousness is sin and there is
a sin not unto death
this is a very interesting question this
verse has always been a one those that
can be controversial a little bit
because of this apparently idea that
there's some sins that are not yeah
how will we answer that person how we
reconcile that well the the Roman
Catholic Church comes up with the idea
that there are mortal sins and venial
sins in the in the basement on this but
uh really what's Happening Here is a sin
that is unto death is a sin that is not
repented of
um
uh in in other words it is a is a
high-handed sin if you please uh and
maybe we can uh pursue that by going to
uh Matthew chapter 12 and verse 31.
Jesus spoke about that sin it's called
the unpardonable sin right
of course
and by the way the unpardonable sin is
not murder or adultery or dishonoring
your parents it is a consistent refusal
to listen to the voice of the holy
spirit so anyway let's read that Matthew
chapter 12 and verse 31. all right it
says
wherefore I send to you all manner of
sin and blasphemy shall be forgiven unto
men but the blasphemy against the Holy
Spirit shall not be forgiven unto men
who is it that convicts us of sin
the Holy Spirit
so what happens when the Holy Spirit
attempts to convict us and we reach a
point where we don't listen to his voice
and we can't hear his voice there's no
you cannot you know you are not able to
be convicted of sin anymore it's like
you are
so sealed in sin that there's nothing
else can he can do for you so who's to
blame for that ourselves we're to blame
for that absolutely is that a sin that
leads to death absolutely
Eternal deaths not only physical death
Eternal deaths right because according
to this it's the sin against the holy
spirit it's a refusal to hear the voice
of the Holy Spirit and the context is
that the religious leaders were accusing
Jesus of casting out demons by the power
of the devil yes yes
and uh and so Jesus says listen the holy
spirit is trying to convict your hearts
that I'm the Messiah
but uh if you insist on saying that what
I'm doing is the work of the devil
you're going to reach the point where
the point of no return in other words
absolutely
um and you know Pastor the the
expression there that John is speaking
as I think it connects really well it
makes it makes makes a lot of sense
because it's telling the person if you
see her your brother doing a sin and
that is not unto that in other words you
can see that you can talk to them
ask them to repent to to turn their life
around you need to do that you need to
offer him life and you know instead of
death and but if you were to see you
know someone that is
pillow has closed their hearts so much
like I'm thinking of pharaoh or in the
examples of the Bible uh you know Jude
Judas or something like that somebody
like that who rejected right to the
point of of not wanting to hear anymore
even or the cases for example of some of
the people that the Apostle Paul spoke
with where he says later I have given
them to Satan there is nothing else you
can do about them you have word you have
done all you could to help them to turn
their life at that point you you're not
able to pray anymore for them and that's
really what I think the puzzle is is
trying to tell us with these verses it's
basically saying well there's a chance
well you see your brother still wanting
to change you gotta do all you can to
reach them help them to to understand
that their sin has not caused them to
separate till death you know they're not
in that condition of a being I'm
pardonable but you gotta do all that you
can to reach them to bring them back to
the Lord yeah Ellen White Once wrote in
steps to Christ that cherished sin
has the power to allow all the power of
the Gospel wow in other words a sin that
is cherished is a sin that you hang on
to and the Holy Spirit says you know
that's wrong what you're doing and we
brush it off
and then each time that the Holy Spirit
speaks his voice is more faint not
because he's speaking more softly but
because we're becoming hard of hearing
and that's when the conference when the
conscience becomes seared the Bible
speaks about the Searing of the
conscience you're right or the hardening
of the conscience of the individual uh
the point comes when the Holy Spirit
speaks and because our our ears are so
hardened that we can't hear him speaking
many more and you know Pastor I think
that some of this some of the things
that can cost anybody even preachers or
whoever you know pastors to fall into
these these deception this delusion
are sins that are not seen by anybody
else you know a lot of the the secret
sins that no one else has but that you
hold on to in your life an age person
needs to understand that you know come
to that you know conviction of the Holy
Spirit to tell you you know you give up
this because if you keep holding on to
these small little sin nobody knows
about that's gonna sear your conscience
against the Holy Spirit and so uh that
is why the verse says if any man sees
their brother because a lot of things
that we can see somebody else do that is
wrong it's is our duty to in love
approach that person and help them to
realize but the warning here is if you
have sins that no one else sees and you
hold on to them and you have that secret
wise or secret scene that is really
making you reject the voice of Holy
Spirit it will come a time when you will
fully be so uh you know searing in in
rejecting the voice of holy spirit that
you will never listen to any anymore to
his word or his voice yeah you know
there's an Old Testament example that I
think would be valuable here uh going
back to the Book of Numbers
uh two kinds of sin are mentioned here
in numbers uh chapter 15
Numbers chapter 15
and um you know beginning at verse 22
right
um
it says if you sin unintentionally
that's the first kind of sin
and do not observe all these
Commandments which the Lord has spoken
to Moses all that the Lord has commanded
you by the hand of Moses from the day
the lord gave commandment and onward
throughout your Generations then it will
be if it is unintentionally committed
without the knowledge of the
congregation that the whole congregation
shall offer one young bull as a burnt
offering as a sweet Aroma to the Lord
with its grain offering and its drink
offering according to the ordinance and
one kid of the goats has a sin offering
so the priest shall make atonement for
the whole Congregation of the children
of Israel and it shall be forgiven them
for it was unintentional and they shall
bring their offering an offering made by
fire to the Lord Etc and then a little
bit later on uh in verse 30 it speaks
about a different kind of sin but the
person who does anything presumptuously
better translation is with a high hand
where the person says God I know you say
shouldn't do this I'm going to do it
anyway
that's the sin with the high hand so it
says but the person who does anything
presumptuously whether he is native born
or a stranger that one brings reproach
on the Lord and he shall be cut off from
among the people because he has despised
the word of the Lord
notice that he has despised the word of
the Lord and has broken his Commandment
that person shall be completely cut off
his guilt shall be upon him and then
next comes an example an example God had
said to Israel
don't pick up sticks to make a fire to
cook on Sabbath
he did allow them by the way to do it in
the winter where it's very cold because
God is a practical God he doesn't want
people to shiver to death on the Sabbath
he doesn't want them to go hungry in the
Sabbath so but in times where the
weather allowed they were not to build a
fire
and so this individual says I know what
God Said tough luck I'm going to do it
anyway
and so he goes out
and he gathers sticks
and the result was that he was not only
cut off from the congregation
he was stoned and so the difference
between
unintentional sin and intentional sin
unintentional sin is a sin due to the
weakness of our human nature
by the way that kind of sin isn't
Justified either of course the power of
the Holy Spirit can convict us once
we've done it and we ask for forgiveness
and God will forgive it absolutely but
the other sin is a sin where the Holy
Spirit shows us that it's sin
and after a process we said I don't much
care what the holy spirit says I'm going
to continue doing that anyway I don't
want to give it up so that is a there
there's a sin that leads to death and
there's another sin that doesn't lead to
death the sin that is repented of does
not lead to death the sin that we're
sorry for does not lead to death the sin
that we cherish annuls all the power of
the Gospel so that the Holy Spirit
speaks and we can't hear him anymore
amen wow
very very deep
by the way the Bible says that Paul
blasphemed Christ
notice as he has said yeah if you speak
words against Christ he'll be forgiven
but if you speak against the Holy Spirit
no and uh and so it says in Acts chapter
26 verse 11 we know that Paul found
repentance he had not committed the
unpardonable sin by persecuting
Christians right uh in the book of Acts
chapter 26
and verse 11. we find the Apostle Paul
giving testimony of his own life
right and uh what does it say you have
that there yeah I have it there it says
and I punish them up in every synagogue
and compel them to blaspheme and being
exceedingly mad against them I
persecuted them even onto strange cities
that's all that he was doing so he led
the the blaspheme Christ wow
yeah yeah so that's an illustration of
what Jesus taught in Matthew chapter 12
and verse 31. praise the Lord amen okay
let's go what does our next question say
the next question says here and uh it's
telling us the following my question is
what it relates to the authority of the
spirit of Prophecy writings I believe
and love the writings of Ellen White my
problem is that I believe that her
writings are as inspired as the books of
Isaiah Jeremiah Paul's writings etc etc
from time to time he quotes from LNG
White's writings but he always states
that her writings are a lesser light and
the Bible is the greater light
I'm assuming is the quotes not hide
quotes the quotes probably the
chromology white writings uh she states
that her writings are lesser light and
the Bible is the greater light I
understand that sister white presents
the Bible but if she was a prophet
messenger why would her writings be less
inspired
I think the problem uh is that her
writings are not less inspired
Ellen White is not of lesser Authority
than the Bible nor are her writings less
inspired
the purpose of her writings have a
different function than the Bible
we've actually misunderstood that
statement which says that the writings
of Illinois are lesser light that leads
to the greater light you know people
think that the greater light is the
Bible and the Lesser light is the
writings of Ellen White but really when
you read the same expression in other
places in the writings of Ellen White
she says that the Lesser light is the
Old Testament uh and the greater light
in other words the the Shadows of the
Old Testament that pointed to Christ and
the greater light is Jesus Christ
correct
um and maybe I can read one of those
statements Desire of Ages 220 the
prophet John because John was also a
lesser light that's right that led to
the greater light in that case the
greater light was whom Jesus Jesus let's
call it John 5 before I read this
statement from Ellen White John 5 and
verses 35 and 36 so that we see that the
Lesser light is John the greater light
is Christ the the Lesser light is Ellen
White and the greater light is Christ
right so the greater light is not the
Bible the greater light is Christ
absolutely according to other statements
of Illinois so let's read John 5 35 and
36. he was a burning and a Shining Light
that's that's John the Baptist right and
ye were willing for a season to rejoice
in his light
but I have greater witness than that of
John
for The Works which the father had given
me to finish the same works that I do
bear witness of me that the father has
sent me so notice John was a burning and
Shining lamp
or light yeah yeah but it's not the word
lucnos in Greek which means a lamp
Jesus is the son he's a son he's a
greater light but John was according to
this John was a burning and Shining lamp
and and Jesus is saying you the Jew the
Jews were willing for a time to rejoice
in his light but then but I have greater
witness than John absolutely so Jesus is
the greatest to whom
John pointed because he was the one that
prepared the way for the coming of the
Messiah
in the same way the writings of Ellen
White are a lesser light that lead
people to the greater light who is Jesus
Christ now it's interesting in the times
of Christ
there were actually two lesser lights
the first lesser light was the Old
Testament
the Old Testament was a lesser light
absolutely because Jesus says these are
they that testify of me which give
witness or testify of me so the Old
Testament was a lesser light that led to
the greater light so people say well why
did why was John the Baptist in lesser
light that led to Christ the greater
light this reason is very simple people
were in darkness and so it was necessary
to turn on the flashlight so you could
find the greater light and so the same
is true with Ellen White the purpose of
Ellen White you know when God raised her
up the Christian world had gone astray
from the teaching of the Bible
absolutely the the Christian world was
in darkness so God says I'm going to
give Ellen White the flashlight to shine
on the pages of the Bible so that people
can find the greater light Jesus Christ
and so both the Bible is a lesser light
and Ellen White is a lesser light to
lead to Jesus Christ the greater light
and you know Pastor I believe that is is
celibate case of many
in positions of responsibility in the
church who have brought these
concept of putting LNG white in a lower
position they have rejected the
authority of her inspiration so that she
no longer is uh you know one that we can
rely on for Doctrine for our own beliefs
you know and it's a dangerous premise
because it allows many new teachings or
ideas to develop when we are clearly
indicated by the spirit prophecy that
certain
beliefs or or or even our way of how or
to worship is to be or who's to be you
know ordained or that kind of thing it's
put away because we are not looking or
accepting the inspiration of the spirit
prophecy as as in the same level as the
Bible itself as far as inspiration goes
and so that's why the enemy has done
these very very I don't know subtle but
also very successfully in putting in the
minds of many people the idea that
energy white is lesser in many ways
because they interpret the word lesser
as inferior God has given an inferior
light to point to the superior light but
really you know this terminology comes
from the Sun and the Moon right you know
when you see the moon at night what is
that pointing to you this is the light
of the sun oh the light of the moon
comes from the Sun so it points to the
sun yeah and so the writings of el white
point to Jesus absolutely the son
and the reason why God raised her is
because people weren't obeying the light
the Bible right so she shines on the
Bible so that people can find Christ in
his doctrines once more well time has
flown by thank you so much for joining
us for our program I'd like to know
today we trust that you will send us
your questions TV at some tv.org see you
next time Lord willing God bless
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]